Let's get into audience questions for the
week.
First one is, hey, David, is being against
immigration necessarily racist?
Couldn't you simply be against immigration,
but not for racist or xenophobic reasons?
Yeah.
I mean, listen, this is I prefer to deal in
reality rather than than in hypotheticals.
Of course, it's possible that you might be
someone who does not care about race or ethnicity.
You're against immigration to the United States
from any country for any reason whatsoever.
Doesn't matter if it's a country of predominantly
white or brown people or if it's a predominantly
rich or poor country.
Sure.
That that exists.
The reality is that in in a vast swaths of
situations, the economic arguments that you
often hear made against immigration really
only end up applying to or people are only
thinking of those from countries where the
immigrants are more brown or black than they
are white.
And we see this in a number of different ways,
which we'll talk about.
You can for sure.
I mean, listen, first of all, there are studies
that show that racism and anti-immigrant sentiment
are highly correlated.
Now, you could be racist and against immigration
for other reasons that are not related to
race or ethnicity.
Sure, that that's quite possible.
But decades of data show us that preconceived
prejudicial notions about race and race and
ethnicity tend to correlate with anti-immigrant
sentiment.
Now, there are many economic questions about
immigration that can be made.
We've analyzed many of them, like, for example,
immigrants are taking the jobs of Americans.
Immigrants reduce wages.
Immigrants are leeching off of the system.
And every single one of these has an answer.
And it's typically not what the anti-immigration
crowd says.
One of the things I think is useful when you're
dealing with
someone who
claims to be just against immigration, period,
is to talk about a situation in which the
immigrants are typically whites from so-called
Western nations and gauge the reaction to
that situation and then talk about immigrants
from countries where people tend to be brown
or black.
Or at least the belief is when you talk about
immigrants from Mexico or Haiti, the people
aren't white.
And see if you get the same reaction.
I mean, it's you know, we can study these
things scientifically and empirically and
it's been done.
But when when you have such a situation, if
it's someone, you know, gauge their reaction,
talk about immigrants from Norway and Sweden
and then talk about immigrants from from Haiti
or Mexico or whatever, whatever the case may
be.
Now, they may say, well, I have a different
opinion about immigrants from Sweden versus
immigrants from Haiti, but it's not because
of race.
It's because it's about skill.
And I believe that for no racially motivated
reason, the people coming from Sweden are
higher skilled than the person than the people
coming from Haiti.
The reality is that there's plenty of highly
skilled computer programmers, engineers, people
in the medical field, accountants coming from
Africa, some of the top engineering and programing
people that I know in the United States are
from Argentina now.
There's an availability bias for sure, me
being from Argentina.
I just know more Argentineans also.
Argentina's mostly white, but a lot of racists
don't realize that they don't know the difference
between Argentina and Mexico and, you know,
Costa Rica or whatever the case may be.
But this is you know, I'm reminded of the
situation with the Israeli BDS movement where
in principle, just saying for political reasons,
Israel should be boycotted.
That's not anti-Semitic.
But the BDS movement is a haven for and provides
cover for many anti-Semitic whose reasons
stated for boycotting Israel could apply to
10 other countries which they either aren't
even aware of or are aware of, but certainly
aren't interested or advocating in boycotting.
So, yes, you can be.
I mean, if you're just trying to get me to
say
you can
be against immigration and not be a racist.
Of course.
Now that we've gotten back beyond the hypothetical,
let's actually deal with the typical reasons
that are given for being against immigration
and see if they're applied equally regardless
of of race or ethnicity.
And you very quickly see how it is a cover
for lots of racists
and xenophobes,